I don't want to end the stream without
playing my new arch nemesis Eric bot I'm
gonna challenge
three plus two
this is a bot that's designed to play
like me at least in the opening
it has studied all of my
my games online
and knows my whole opening tree with
your Bishops
oh yeah I missed an opportunity there
and we're gonna go into
[Music]
a standard Gambit
I played it a few times yesterday it
kept crushing me on the Stafford even
though I thought I knew what I was doing
let's play a slightly different line
this time let's play D3
which I did play yesterday but then I'm
gonna play Bishop E2
H5 I know it's coming because I play
this as black and I don't play H3 it's
gonna play Queen D4
like Castle
I was gonna play this
I play this
and it plays this
and now here
of course there's a main thread it's not
good to take because takes and then
there's still issues G3 gets mated but
there's a move E5
and this is supposed to be good
but I don't know if I've seen this move
before Queen G6
can I take it
is it bluffing
maybe maybe D4
I should probably play D4
no need to like mess with it too much
it takes takes
I actually don't see like the defense
I really want to call its Bluff
wow
play like a four
maybe bishop here
Bishop D3 so Knight stays hanging the
Queen's attacked
can take
can I get away with taking
I think I can take something rookie one
I'm nervous though also my time is
ticking why did I challenge it to Blitz
working one
oh it's so so risky though
let's play this let's be safe
I'll still take in the night doesn't
seem to be working in Queen F3
now there's an increment here if so
at some point I might have to live on
the increments
okay that's some success we can trade
Queens
C5 might be coming I have to be careful
yeah it sometimes talks
I think it says this at the beginning of
every game
ka3
it's basically playing like stockfish
now like now that's out of the opening
I like the fact I have the a file
94 some idea Knight C5
Bishop D2 safer
I really just want to simplify I'm
scared of this idea though
maybe I should have played Bishop E3
prepare C4
that's gonna do things with its king
I have like G4
oh dear
I'm running low on time
King D5 I think is coming
that's insane how it's just like it's
controlling the position even though
I'm up a pawn I have the pawn Center
there's no more Knight C5
B6 was a great move
I think I'm still holding on
but I feel like the tides are turning
okay
hmm
[Music]
some tension remains
don't hurt me
wow key four
my whole position about to crumble
I have this move
these King takes I have the fork
trying to live on increments
and not die on the increments
foreign
[Music]
otherwise Knight G2
that's terrifying though
it's contemplating
it takes takes
I think I'm on the verge of losing but I
might be close to drawing
I don't know what's happening
I have to take
I mean this is a huge success to have
survived
what seemed to be a very difficult spot
but my knight is stuck
wait how do I get my knight out of here
I'm completely stuck
I play G5 G4
a G5 soon
it's also getting low on time
okay G5 coming
and that F6 is guaranteed
once I got an is six I escape
and this should be a draw now
let's go
okay
oh
someone call an ambulance
but not for either of us
okay
wow
I really thought I was losing at some
point though
but somehow
like it went wrong
yeah this position the position is dead
lost
but where did it go wrong
King D4
yeah King D4 was like a slightly strange
move
I should have challenged the serrated
could have farmed it a little bit
it makes the same blunders as me yeah
maybe uh
the programming has been refined to mess
up end games I do struggle with
converting winning positions sometimes
and I I follow the rule always play F6
yeah so I made two like very bad moves
in a row
King F5 is completely winning because
like here
here
but how does black actually win
I guess just wins all the pawns I I
can't even move
um if I wait with my king H3 Falls
and I guess once I get to play G5 it's
too late
because Knight F6 takes takes here here
here here and this is a Wing King Pawn
engine
what a game I did have the opening
advantage
D4 plus almost four
but look at the graph like it gradually
outplayed me from
a bad position
what was this moment
I was still better if I played Knight C5
all right well that was fun this is my
first non-loss against Eric bot
um I'll have to maybe do a series where
I
I play against this boss